on l'a posé la question à ce black block
aussi la question tout le monde se pose
est ce que posent tous les français
après avoir vu les images de samedi
dernier et ce qui culpabilisent de voir
toutes ces images et de voir toutes ces
violences écoutez sa réponse
certaines personnes n'ont aucune
culpabilité maintenez-vous un
démantèlement des bâtiments tout casser
du flic des classes et des magasins moi
personnellement c'est donc entre plus
dans tout ce qui est matériel récupéré
les scolaires
même si les gens qui travaillent
derrière ces bretons ont détruit mais
après ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
l'on va le capitalisme donc en l'état et
l'itouch comptant beaucoup plus les fous
en faillite une famille un haut niveau
la banque et l'état tient une femme de
80 ans et marsal personnes en temps un
capitaliste où les gens vivent dans le
chômage et la précarité et on apporte un
pour nous emmener à sa 5e finale c'est
ici qu'il en soit on a bien fait pendant
des années et des années que dans les
manifestations pacifiques ne
fonctionnait pas ce soit contre volume
et en traitant les mêmes comment ils
étaient les mots d' actions plus
violentes diarrhées
on fonctionne et n'est pas parce à notre
dame de londres on l'a bien vu tous les
temps la violence c'est faire face à
face malheureusement c'est la seule
chose que le gouvernement compris
malheureusement quand vous serez
toujours manifesté pendant 81 ans
commandant lyon s'est plus passé en mode
d'action que nous fait rêver moi je ne
pense pas que les casseurs ont tué le
mouvement des gilet jaune
je pense qu'il l'a il le desservent ils
l'ont affaibli en terme d'image mais ils
ne l'ont pas tué pour la bonne et simple
raison que tant qu'il n'y aura pas de
réponse politique faite aux
revendications initiales le mouvement
perdurera
il faut se le dire après c'est vrai qu'à
moins de monde dans la rue et c'est pas
parce qu'il ya moins de monde dans la
rue que des gilets jaunes encore une
fois du 17 novembre que j'appellerais
canal historique des retraités qui
étaient jamais sorties de chez eux
quittés et qu'il n'avait jamais été
syndiqué qui pour certains n'ont même
n'ont pas voté ne votez pas un moment
donné cette souffrance cette colère
s'est pas les blagues box qui veut qui
va qui valent annihiler cette souffrance
ils desservent le mouvement ça c'est à
l'évidence ils font mal au mouvement
initial populaires légitimes des
citoyens mais